13 5 milliarden euro so viel geld konnte
der bund in 2009 10 nicht ausgeben
jetzt müssen endlich die steuern gesenkt
werden und der soli ganz abgeschafft
werden sagen die einen
die anderen sagen trotz der rekord
einnahme sei jetzt die zeit um schulden
zu machen und die schwarze null
aufzugeben bringen uns neue schulden
wirklich in die zukunft was ist gerecht
für künftige generation das diskutiere
ich jetzt mit meinen gästen
[Musik]
herzlich willkommen zu unter den linden
ich freue mich sehr auf meine beiden
gäste bei uns friedrich merz vize
präsident des wirtschaftsrats der cdu
und bei uns professor masse fratzscher
präsident des deutschen instituts für
wirtschaftsforschung schön dass sie
dabei sind
herr merz csu-chefs söder hat ja das
politische jahr direkt mit einer
forderung nach kabinettsumbildung
begonnen jetzt mal betrachten wir mal
wirtschaft und finanzen unser thema
heute was wenn sie sagen braucht es da
tatsächlich neue minister oder
ministerin wo wir was kinder treten oder
warum wir über geld reden erst mal die
frage beantworten also ich finde wir
haben wenn wir die ganze themen als
dessert hat da einen vorschlag gemacht
und der vorschlag steht im raum und
alles weitere wird man sehen
ok professor fratzscher wie sehen sie
das
glauben sie dass wir ein gutes signal
jetzt erst mal im kabinett umzubilden
für mich ist nicht die frage ob personen
andere sein sollten sondern für mich
geht's um inhalte und ganz klar ist dass
die große koalition wichtige
herausforderungen auch wirklich angeht
im bereich klimaschutz im bereich
zukunftsinvestitionen im bereich europa
reformieren die globalen
herausforderungen mit donald trump
annehmen deshalb bin ich schon der
meinung ist halt nicht um gesichter und
personen gehen sondern die große
koalition sollte mehr mut haben die
wichtige reform wirklich anzugehen
da gibt es direkt erstmals zustimmung
vielleicht mal so wirklich einfach
liegen wir mal auf deutschland im
letzten jahr haben ja alle doch sehr
eindringlich von der rezession gewarnt
und jetzt blicken die meisten ökonomen
sie selbst auch optimistisch auf die
entwicklung sie selbst haben gesagt sie
rechne mit 1,2 prozent
wirtschaftswachstum und 150000
zusätzlichen neuen jobs woher jetzt der
optimismus wir schon sehen deutschland
hat eine sehr starke wirtschaft wir
haben wir starke substanz im unternehmen
die sehr wettbewerbsfähig sind im
globalen vergleich exportieren sehr sehr
gut
wir haben hervorragenden arbeitsmarkt
rekord niedrige arbeitslosenquote und
das resultat auch heute was wir gesehen
haben der staat steht finanziell
hervorragend da das ist erstmal die
lager sowie stehen wirtschaftlich heute
wirklich sehr sehr gut da meine große
sorge ist aber diese stärke kann sehr
schnell auch zu einer schwäche werden
denn man sieht jetzt mit konflikten
mittleren osten mit iran wo die ölpreise
durch die decke schießen wo der
welthandel geschwächt wird unser
wirtschaftsmodell in deutschland hängen
von exporten ab und die gefahr war
selten höher als heute dass irgendetwas
schiefgehen könnte ein handelskonflikt
mit den usa konnte politischer konflikte
mittleren osten der praxis der kommt
probleme in italien aber auch
hausgemachte probleme hier in
deutschland also es geht uns gut aber
gleichzeitig muss man auch sagen wir
haben enorm hohe risiken
das viel schiefgehen könnte und einer
solchen lage muss die politik eigentlich
klug als risikomanager ergeben also
sagen was muss die politik heute tun
damit diese risiken nicht eintreten
und dass die zukunftsinvestitionen also
dass es in zehn 15 20 jahren auch noch
viele gute jobs gibt und die
wettbewerbsfähigkeit der deutschen
wirtschaft immer noch hoch weise diese
zwei herausforderungen die risiken
minimieren und gleichzeitig langfristig
planen das sehe ich als sie zwei
stellschrauben für die bundesregierung
okay das klingt ja schon gar nicht mehr
so optimistisch wie sehen sie dieses
herz wie ist die stimmungslage es gerade
schon gehört deutschland als
exportnation ist natürlich sehr abhängig
von dem wie es auf der welt aussieht wie
kann sich dann zb der iran konflikt
jetzt auswirken
alles nicht so weit will ich doch sagen
es geht uns wirklich jetzt seit zehn
jahren gut wir haben den längsten
wirtschaftlichen aufschwung in den
letzten jahren erlebt den es in der
wirtschaftsgeschichte seit dem
neunzehnten jahrhundert gibt eine solche
phase hat es noch nie gegeben
und wenn wir vor zehn jahren hier
gesetzen hätten hätte wahrscheinlich
genau dasselbe gesagt und hätte gesagt
auch alles ganz schwierig und jetzt wird
man vorsorgen und krisenmanager also wie
die voraussetzungen dafür dass es in den
nächsten jahren weiter gut geht sind da
übrigens auch in der umweltpolitik der
meinung wir sollten vielmehr auch mal
schauen was wir schon erreicht haben gab
in den letzten 30 jahren die
wirtschaftsleistung dieses landes um 50
prozent erhöht und haben den co2 ausstoß
umfasst
sich prozent reduziert das zeigt doch
dass die mechanismen funktionieren die
da vor 15 jahren in der europäischen
union eingeführt worden sind mit der
begrenzung von co2 also es gibt so
pessimismus überhaupt keinen anlass
es gibt anlass das ein oder andere thema
zu diskutieren und zum beispiel die hohe
bürokratie last der unternehmen die hohe
abgaben und steuerlast auch der privaten
haushalte und der unternehmen
darüber kann man diskutieren da könnte
deutschland in der tat besser sein noch
besser sein aber ich sehe überhaupt
keinen grund für den pessimismus im
gegenteil es gibt viel grund auch die
nächsten jahre sehr zuversichtlich
anzugehen
zuversicht ist heute ein stichwort 13 5
milliarden euro überschuss das ist ja
doch ordentlich
nichtsdestotrotz fordern ökonomen wie
sie und auch teile der spd also die
beiden vorsitzenden dass deutschland
wieder richtig schulden macht und die
schwarze null aufgibt und erklären sie
uns doch mal warum soll dieses mantra
was wir immer vor uns her getragen haben
nicht mehr gelten
deutsch soll keine schulden nach wir
leben den wirtschaftlich guten zeiten
nur was mir der diskussion zu kurz kommt
dass viel zu viel auf die schulden
fokussiert wird was muss der staat den
bürgern zurückzahlen was ist ein
verschuldung da haben was wir ignorieren
ist das was an vermögen da ist und
tatsache ist in den letzten 15 jahren
sind die vermögenswerte der staat ist
die wer wird von brücken von straßen von
schuleinrichtungen von öffentlichen
vermögen die wir haben schneller
gesunken als die schulden also obwohl
eigentlich die lage gut aussieht der
staat an überschüsse ist der wertverfall
der substanz der fall das was wir haben
noch viel größer und da das zeigt sehr
deutlich der staat lebt von der substanz
jeder von uns kennt das verfallene
schulgebäude eine schlechte
infrastruktur ein miserables digitale
infrastruktur und das ist ja eigentlich
keine zukunftssicherung also schulden ja
man muss gucken dass die schulden nicht
weiter steigen oder zumindest stabil
bleiben aber ganz genau so wichtig ist
zu schauen was steht demgegenüber steht
ihm ein vermögen gegenüber den wenn es
darum geht wohlstand zu wahren künftige
jobs zu sichern gute jobs zu schaffen
dann geht es doch darum dass wir eine
leistungsfähige verkehrsinfrastruktur
hervorragendes bildungssystem haben eine
exzellente digitale infrastruktur haben
und da haben wir die großen probleme
heute wir haben eine der schlechtesten
digitale infrastrukturen das ist dann
nicht ein problem für uns die
telefonieren wollen sie dann für
unternehmen
darum ist das so also müssten wir jetzt
mehr schulden machen um deutschlands
vermögenswerte wieder nach vorne zu
bringen oder wie schaffen wir das denn
erstmal sollte man das was man an
finanziellen spielraum hat wirklich
nutzen damit für zukunftsinvestitionen
auszugeben also ein besseres
bildungssystem digitale infrastruktur
wir können das man kann er sehr schnell
auf verdienen und der breite konsens ist
es fehlen ungefähr 30 bis 40 milliarden
euro ungefähr ein prozent der
wirtschaftsleistung in deutschland
öffentlichen investitionen und man
sollte erstens die überschüsse nehmen
die man hat und zweitens ja schulden
aufnehmen aber wie gesagt nicht schulden
um schulden zu machen sondern schulden
um produktiv in die zukunft zu
investieren weil wenn sie heute in ein
besseres bildungssystem dass die kinder
jugendliche besser ausgebildet werden
dann rechnet sich ja dass die menschen
sind ja dann produktiver am bessere
chancen arbeit zu finden
zahner wieder steuern also es kommt
letztlich auch hinter dem staat zugute
also dieses denken man muss bloß keinen
euro ausgeben und alles auf die hohe
kante legen
das ist wirklich die allerschlechteste
wirtschaftspolitik sondern muss sich
fragen was muss in die zukunft
investiert werden und dann sind wir ganz
schnell dort dass wir sagen da haben wir
ein riesiges problem die politik tut
nicht genug um diese probleme zu beheben
okay er hat sie verteidigen ja die
schwarze null und sagen die muss auch
genau so bleiben
gerade an einem tag wie heute mit diesem
überschuss sehen sie sich da sehr
bestätigt also wir haben um vielleicht
einmal zu erläutern was im augenblick
tatsächlich passiert wir haben 13 5
milliarden überschuss allein im
bundeshaushalt aus dem jahr 2019 und der
staat ist zurzeit nicht in der lage das
geld das er durch die steuereinnahmen
hat und die sind auf rekordniveau
auszugeben so wir haben nicht zu wenig
geld wir haben zu viel bürokratie
wir haben zu viele hindernisse auf dem
weg hin in die investitionen und der
vater sie und einige ihrer kollegen
machen ja gerade den vorschlag jetzt
schulden zu machen
und es ist ein absurder vorschlag wir
haben nicht ein problem mit zu wenig
geld wir kriegen dieses geld nicht
verbaut ja keiner aufführen aber woran
liegt das
darüber müssen wir reden weil der staat
viel gespart hat bauämter ausgedünnt hat
leute nicht neu erstellte die
kapazitäten und dann ist es auch kein
wunder dass sie denn der bund sagt hier
ihr grün hier habt ihr das geld gibt das
bitte außen die kommunen sagen wir haben
gar nicht die möglichkeit das geld zu
verplanen
also dass bürger legen dass ich einem
planungsbüro das liegt dann in
planungsprozessen das liegt an den
jahrelangen prozessen die geführt werden
gegen jedes vorhaben also wenn sie mit
der selben intensität in den
forschungsinstituten unterwegs wären und
sie sind ja haben ja eine dienende
funktion auch dem staat gegenüber dafür
werden sie auch bezahlt mal vorschläge
zu machen wie wir aus diesem bürokratie
dickicht heraus kommen wir zum beispiel
mal das problem lösen mit den
umweltverbänden und ihren klagen gegen
alles was in diesem land geplant wird
dann gegen das verbandsklagerecht mal
vorschläge machen die man das etwas
eindämmen kann auf die wirklich
wichtigen und notwendigen themen dann
kämen wir sehr viel schnell sehr viel
schneller weiter mit investitionen auch
in die öffentliche infrastruktur lehrer
ausbildung ja die länder haben in den
letzten jahren zu wenig gemacht aber die
kriegen sie nicht mit schulden heute von
heute auf morgen in die schulen sondern
die kriegen sie nur mit guten
ausbildungswegen in den universitäten
und dafür geld vorhanden
das dauert alles seine zeit also diese
schwarze null ist kein kein popanz kein
fetisch an dem mandat festhalten muss
aber wir haben wachstum
wir haben hohe steuereinnahmen die sogar
höher sind als das wachstum
und wir haben in den nächsten jahr jetzt
überschreiten wir 800 milliarden euro
steuereinnahmen in diesem jahr im jahr
2023 überschreiten man 900 milliarden
euro steuereinnahmen pro jahr also ein
land mit 80 millionen einwohnern muss
doch mit 800 milliarden euro
steuereinnahmen auskommen ohne neue
schulden zu machen
im übrigen meine kinder und ihre müssen
die schulden irgendwann bezahlen wenn
wir in einer rezession kämen und
wirklich mal die steuereinnahmen
einbrechen würden hätten wir jeden
spielraum auch nach unserem grundgesetz
mit der schuldenbremse auch wieder
schulden zu machen aber jetzt zu diesem
zeitpunkt wo wir wachstum beschäftigung
und hohe steuereinnahmen haben über
schuldenaufnahme zu diskutieren
entschuldung das bleibt für mich
ziemlich absurd daher die fragen musste
wir reden über die kinder wir reden über
generationengerechtigkeit was im
interesse der künftigen generation keine
schulden zu haben
im augenblick übrigens dem start 0
prozent zinsen kosten also der eine der
wichtigsten gründe für die gute lagen
haushalt ist dass der staat immer
weniger zinsen zahlen muss auf die
schulden mittlerweile negativ für eine
zehnjährige staatsanleihe was ist
wichtiger keine schulden keine steuern
um schulden zu bezahlen zu müssen oder
gute jobs zu haben
im wettbewerbsfähigen unternehmen die im
globalen wettbewerb bestehen können weil
die unternehmen gute rahmenbedingungen
deutschland haben zu investieren gute
digitale netze gute
verkehrsinfrastruktur die menschen eine
hervorragende ausbildung haben und die
klare ansage ist natürlich ist es
deutlich wichtiger dass wir klimaschutz
haben eine intakte umwelt wohlstand zu
wahren und jobs zu haben als sie schulen
und da wusste vor dem mietwagen in das
neue schulden im gegensatz zu früher
sogar gerade generationengerecht sind
wenn man an die großen herausforderung
denkt absolut generationen gerecht wenn
man über gerade über klimaschutz redet
wir sehen doch schon was der was der die
wie naturkatastrophen und der
klimawandel an massiven kosten
verursacht kluge investitionen für im
klimawandel zu verhindern oder noch
stärken klimawandel zu verhindern damit
umzugehen das ist eigentlich
generationengerechtigkeit und wenn man
sich auch ehrlich macht herr merz dann
dann realisiert man wir werden nicht
beides realisieren können schwarze null
überschüsse machen und gleichzeitig die
großen zukunft investitionen zu tätigen
das suggeriert die bundesregierung immer
sagt wir können ja beides machen aber
eine ehrliche ansage ist das können sie
eben nicht man muss sich wirklich
entscheiden was ist ein wichtiger
zukunftsinvestitionen oder die schwarze
mann aber es ist ja gerade so jetzt ist
ja gerade so dass das geld aus dem
energie und klimafonds gar nicht
abgerufen wurde also dass da tatsächlich
noch milliarden liegen geblieben sind
wie kann man das den bürgern erklären
dass wenn dieses geld gar nicht
abgerufen wird dass es trotzdem noch
mehr geld bedarf geld ist ja nicht nur
da um geld auszugeben sondern es fehlt
dem staat in vielen bereichen
kapazitäten herz hat völlig zu recht
angesprochen war ich lehrer haben zu
wenig lehrer wir haben zu wenig
fachpersonal wir haben zu wenig
pflegekräfte
wir haben zu wenig kapazitäten
planungskapazitäten gerade bei den
kommunen über die hälfte aller
investitionen werden von den kommunen
getätigt im öffentlichen bereich 30
prozent der kommunen sind überschuldet
können das gar nicht also die können gar
nicht ist die die leute einstellen um
das zu bewältigen ich bin bei herr merz
dass wir ein großes problem mit der
bürokratie haben das ist eine große
herausforderung es bürokratie abgebaut
werden muss genehmigungsverfahren stelle
stattfinden müssen aber die kommunen
müssen auch wieder mehr geld haben um
personal aufzubauen um überhaupt solche
gelder abrufen zu können also wie würden
sie das denn tun
die kommunen was müsste passieren es
müsste erst einmal passieren dass
kommunen entschuldigt werden wir haben
30 prozent der kommende überschuldet
sind wir brauchen eigentlich einen
schuldenschnitt für die kommunen dass
sie entlastet werden 2000 hat dabei
einig darüber schluss noch mal wieder
unschuldig hat ist wichtig damit die
kommunen wieder handlungsfähig sind
zweitens brauchen kommunen mehr
autonomie und das dritte allerwichtigste
ist wir brauchen einen langfristigen
investitionsprogramm eine vision
ja wenn sie den kommunen oder auch
unternehmen sagen hier ist wir gehen mit
20 milliarden mehr geld aus für ein oder
zwei jahre da wird ja keiner kapazitäten
aufbauen als unternehmer werden sie hier
nur dann neue menschen einstellen neue
maschinen kaufen wenn sie wissen dass
wird für 10 oder 15 jahre weitergehen
großer konsens bei uns
wirtschaftswissenschaftlern zu sagen wir
brauchen eigentlich über einen über zehn
15 jahre angelegte
desinvestitionsprogramm in deutschland
wo verlässlichkeit drin ist wo die
unternehmen aber auch die kommunen
wissen da kommt geld das steht zur
verfügung wir können wirklich
langfristig planen also das ist
eigentlich die essenz um dieses problem
zu lösen
lieber mal die beiden punkte einen
schuldenschnitt und investitionsschutz
fällig rechtlich kommen aus nordrhein
westfalen da ist die lage sogar noch ein
bisschen schwieriger für die kommunen
die kommunen entschulden ja das kann man
machen es ist zuallererst aufgabe der
länder und nicht des bundes aber das
kann man auch in einer gemeinsamen
anstrengung machen dann muss man aber
dafür sorgen dass die kommunen auf dauer
einnahmequellen haben die dieses problem
nicht in 10 oder 20 jahren wieder
entstehen lassen und das heißt wir
müssen uns dann über eine steuerreform
unterhalten die auch die gewerbesteuer
körperschaftsteuer
einkommensteuer umfasst und die kommunen
müssen eigene steuerquellen haben damit
dieses problem nicht noch mal entsteht
das wäre aus meiner sicht eine
vernünftige kombination und dann könnte
man auch über die entschuldung der
kommunen reden das zweite ist lassen wir
nochmal zu den schulden etwas sagen ist
ja nicht so als ob wir keine schulden
haben dieser staat bund länder und
gemeinden haben 2000 milliarden euro so
dass wir dazu im augenblick keine zinsen
zahlen ist ein hoffentlich
vorübergehenden zustand
irgendwann wird sich das wieder ändern
wir müssen runter von diesen hohen
schulden die wir haben und nicht neue
oben drauf packen und wenn wir so hohe
steuereinnahmen haben dann können wir
auch zusagen geben für die nächsten zehn
jahre für investitionen wenn die
konjunktur zurückgeht wenn es eine
rezession geben sollte dies nicht in
sicht aber wenn es sie geben sollte dann
gibt das grundgesetz genügend spielraum
her um auch kredite aufzunehmen um diese
investition auch dauerhaft fest zusagen
dauerhaft im übrigen der mittelfristigen
finanzplanung des bundes ist genau das
gemacht was er gerade vorgestellt hat
und erfordert das ist gemacht das fest
sie sagen den investitionszeitraum daran
liegt dass ich will mal auch noch auf
einen aspekt hinweisen der vielleicht
vollkommen unberücksichtigt bleibt in
dieser diskussion wir sind
vertragspartner eines stabilitäts und
wachstumspakts der europäischen union
und des maastricht-vertrages und in
diesem maastricht vertrag hat sich
deutschland wie viele andere staaten
auch verpflichtet in guten zeiten keine
schulden zu machen sondern ausgeglichene
haushalte zu haben oder überschüsse das
machen wir im augenblick wir verhalten
uns vertragstreu das was die
wirtschaftsforschungsinstitute teilweise
vorschlagen ist ein eklatanter bruch des
maastricht-vertrages so und wenn wir
damit wieder anfangen wir haben schon
mal angefangen damit 2003 wenn wir damit
wieder anfangen dürfen uns nicht darüber
wundern dass alle anderen länder in der
europäischen union sagen die deutschen
das mache dann machen wir das auch wir
haben nicht zu wenig schulden haben zu
viele schulden in der welt wird ein
schuldenberg aufgetragen in china in
amerika in europa in den privaten
haushalten in den unternehmen und in den
staatlichen haushalten also das plädoyer
jetzt noch mehr schulden zu machen werde
ich mir nicht zu eigen machen das ist
ein instrument für eine rezession und
eine rezession ist nicht mehr
dass er sich anders herr merz es gibt da
investitionsprogramm nicht darum eine
rezession zu bekämpfen sondern die frage
muss doch sein
was muss der staat in diesen guten
jahren also wir uns ja einig und diesen
guten jahren heute tun damit in zehn
jahren in 20 jahren künftige
generationen und deutschland als
wirtschaftsstandort immer noch
wettbewerbs ist einfach das ist die
große frage und da gibt es nicht in der
rezession in ein oder zwei der fünf
jahren und da sehen wir doch die
herausforderung ganz klar wir stehen
immer mehr im globalen wettbewerb mit
china auf der seite haben wir usa die
immer weniger multilaterale handelt
immer mehr auf konfrontationskurs gehen
wir haben die automobilbranche die für
deutschland enorm wichtig ist die vor
einer riesigen transformation steht
transformation hin zur elektromobilität
oder oder wasserstoff aber in anderen
antrieb zu autonomen fahren und da muss
die frage sein was muss der staat tun um
die rahmenbedingungen für diese
unternehmen zu verbessern und dazu eine
leistungsfähige digitale bücher haben
immer das kostet eine leistungsfähige
digitale infrastruktur kostet in
deutschland zwischen 60 und 100
milliarden euro pro jahr sondern als
gesamtsumme wirklich flächendeckend
glasfaser oder schnelles internet zu
haben
nehmen sie das bereich bildung
deutschland steht im bildungsbereich im
mittelfeld von demo cd von den
industrieländern
wenn wir diesen wohlstand diesen
vorsprung halten wollen die wir heute in
deutschland haben dann muss das
bildungssystem besser werden dass das
kostet geld und das da können sie nicht
mal sagen das machen wir mal in fünf
oder zehn alleine sondern hat jetzt
gerade ging war aber die schuldenbremse
die hat im grundgesetz verankert ist und
wo die dieses maß der neuverschuldung ja
festgelegt ist wie wollen sie denn dem
begegnen würden sie sagen die
schuldenbremse muss abgeschafft werden
dafür bräuchte ich eine zwei drittel
mehrheit oder sagen sie das muss mir die
zertifiziert werden
wie soll das denn gehen die
schuldenbremse ist aus zwei gründen
eigentlich ökonomisch recht nicht
politisch aber ökonomisch unsinnig zum
41 dazu dass sie die schulden den
schuldenstand das was eigentlich zählt
sie nicht die zwei milliarden euro
sollten die schulden des staates relativ
zur wirtschaftsleistung das ist was
zählt da ist deutschland komplett der
chor mit den europäischen regeln unter
60 prozent
sie wollen ja nicht dass die schulden
auf einen schuldenstand von null sinken
dass das macht eigentlich keinen sinn
denn auch die staatsschulden haben eine
ganz wichtige rolle im finanzsystem
also wenn man in deutschland jedes jahr
35 prozent neuverschuldung hat er diese
schuldenstandquote stabil bleiben das
ist ein erster kritikpunkt der
vielleicht wichtige kritikpunkte ist die
schuldenbremse erlaubt es dem start in
guten zeiten zu expansiv zu sein aber in
schlechten zeiten erlaubt es ihnen nicht
stabilisieren genug zu wirken also die
ökonomen sagen konnte zügig sie wollen
wenn einem wirtschaft in eine rezession
fällt das der staat schnell effektiv
agieren kann um die wirtschaft zu
stabilisieren und das tut die das
erlaubt die schulden weil sie nicht aus
dem sinn macht sie keinen sinn für mich
ist vielleicht der wichtigste posten
werden dafür die schuldenbremse
abzuschaffen also dafür reicht es ja
wirklich eine zeitreise hatte wollte es
nicht wer dafür die schuldenbremse
abzuschaffen ich glaube es wird nicht
passieren deshalb ist das was ich als
sinnvoll erachte die schuldenbremse zu
ergänzen mit einer investitions regel
allen bund ländern kommunen zu sagen ja
ihr müsst euch eine schuldenbremse
halten aber die investition in das
bildungssystem eine gute infrastruktur
darf darunter nicht leiden das was ich
eben beschrieben habe dass die
nettoinvestitionen also der verlust der
wertverlust auf öffentliche vermögen
größer ist als was an neuen investition
geschieht das darf eigentlich nicht sein
der staat lebt heute von seiner substanz
deshalb würde wär mein vorschlag
pragmatischer vorschlag wenn man die
schulden oder wahrscheinlich abschafft
dann bitte ergänzt mit einer
investitions regel um sicherzustellen
dass eben nicht die künftigen
generationen dafür zahlen müssen können
sie sich so eine investitionsrate
vorstellen ich will mal ein konkretes
beispiel sagen wo war wo wir uns dann
vielleicht doch treffen indem wir mal
das thema digitale infrastruktur in
deutschland will wir haben in der tat
ein problem und wir haben ein problem
dass es nicht erst gestern entstanden
das haben wir schon seit vielen jahren
wir wir hinken ja seit vielen jahren
schon bei 3g 4g 5 g hinter den
entwicklungen vieler anderer länder
zurück kehrt man mal angeschaut worden
das eigentlich liegt wir haben wir
mittlerweile um die 70 milliarden euro
lizenzgebühren von den unternehmen
verlangt die diese digitale
infrastruktur bauen sollen die 5g
lizenzen haben über sechs milliarden
euro gekostet
andere länder haben den unternehmen
gesagt er kriegt die lizenzen relativ
preisgünstig aber er hat
den auftrag und mit diesem mit dieser
lizenz vergabe verbindet sich der
auftrag müsste innerhalb von drei jahren
die infrastruktur bauen so unsere
unternehmen bekommen das geld erst mal
entzogen der stadtverein haben das in
den 13,5 milliarden überschuss des
bundes sind diese 6 milliarden dollar
hätte man den unternehmen das gilt
gelassen dann werden die in der lage
gewesen sehr viel schneller auch im
ländlichen bereich
diese infrastruktur auszubauen sowie
andere länder in europa das gemacht
haben also ich folge der philosophie
nicht dass der staat das geld erst alles
einnehmen muss um es dann großzügig
wieder auszugeben sondern ich sage mal
private haushalte mit niedrigen steuern
wissen mit ihrem geld auch was
anzufangen unternehmen mit einer
niedrigen steuerbelastung wissen mit dem
geld auch zu investieren also wir
sollten nicht immer nur auf den staat
schauen sondern wir sollten auch auf
diejenigen schauen die eigentlich in
einer offenen marktwirtschaftlichen
volkswirtschaft investieren sollen und
müssen und das sind die unternehmen und
die bekommen zum beispiel durch diese
lizenzvergabe so wie wir das in
deutschland machen und wir machen das ja
seit 30 jahren so das ist nichts neues
wir machen das seit 30 jahren so wie wir
im letzten jahr auch gemacht haben diese
unternehmen bekommen geld entzogen und
kriegen dann noch die auflage jetzt
sollen sie investieren und das geht ja
das heißt sie wären dafür die
unternehmenssteuern zu senken damit die
unternehmen selbst mehr investiert haben
in deutschland mittlerweile mit die
höchsten steuern wir haben im
oecd-vergleich wir haben in deutschland
die höchsten energiekosten in der fast
ganzen welt jedenfalls in europa wir
haben mit die höchste steuer und
abgabenbelastung der privaten haushalte
wenn wir mal sozialversicherungsbeiträge
und steuern addiert da ist spielraum für
entlastung die diese koalition nicht
nutzt aus gründen die wir alle kennen
aber wir müssen zumindest einmal in der
perspektive darüber reden private
haushalte und unternehmen auch von
diesem steuern wieder etwas zu entlasten
dann wird auch wieder mehr investiert
und sie glauben dass durch die
investitionen der unternehmen die
grossen zukunftsprojekte sich dann
alleine in ihrem unternehmen werden
nicht anfangen in die schulen zu
investieren ja aber unternehmen die
investieren in die digitale
infrastruktur also digitale
infrastruktur ist bei uns keine
staatsaufgabe sondern ist in erster
linie aufgabe der unternehmen der staat
muss rahmenbedingungen dafür schaffen
gucken sich andere länder an die das
viel besser gemacht haben sie brauchen
ja nur nach osteuropa zu reisen
fahren sie in die osteuropäischen länder
da haben sie ohne jede unterbrechung
gute internetverbindung gute
funkverbindung bei uns können sie
dann nicht mehr auf den autobahnen
fahren ohne dass ständig
telefongespräche unterbrochen werden
diese länder haben das besser gemacht
und da sollten wir eher ein beispiel
daran übrigens das sind fast alles
länder die eine niedrige
staatsschuldenquote haben als wir und
die arbeitsmärkte sind in allen ländern
dort wo die schulden niedrig ist in
einer guten verfassung überall da wo die
schulden hoch sind sind auch die
arbeitsmärkte in einer schlechten
verfassung keine analyse nein nutzen
teil ja unternehmen müssten anreize
bekommen mehr investieren zu können aber
nicht per gießkannenprinzip also nicht
über eine eine flächendeckende
steuersenkung für unternehmen
die unternehmen machen extrem hohe
gewinne das kommt auch den
bundesfinanzminister zugute also ein
grund für diese gute steuerliche
einnahmen lage ist dass die unternehmen
sehr hohe gewinne machen sehr
wettbewerbsfähig sind im globalen
vergleich und den niedriger steuern zu
geben noch mehr gewinne wird die
investition ich wollte einmal einen
kurzen einfach mal reden wir mal
annehmen dass wir alle kennen und die
bilanz dieses unternehmens kennen sie
auch gucken sich mal die deutsche
telekom die deutsche telekom macht ihre
gewinne fast nur noch in amerika kaum
noch in deutschland und in deutschland
zahlen sie diese hohen lizenzgebühren
ich bin nicht der pressesprecher der
deutschen telekom aber das unternehmen
gehört zu einem teil dem bund warum
entzieht man diesem unternehmen das geld
über die lizenzgebühren und anschließend
beklagen sich alle darüber dass die
digitale infrastruktur nicht ausgebaut
ich schieß unternehmen macht in
deutschland nicht die gewinne die sie
hier mal beschreiben es ist leider ist
es anders wäre schön wenn zu wäre also
zwei punkte erstmal flächendeckend wenn
sie alle unternehmen anschauen stimmt
die aussage die einnahmen
steuereinnahmen die unternehmensgewinne
also es gibt sicherlich 1 unternehmen
oder das anders sein kann wir können
auch die deutsche bank noch nenne ich
glaube einzelfälle bringen sie nicht
weiter bereits deutsche telekom
wissen sie auch das ist jetzt kein markt
ein großer wettbewerb ist es gibt viele
komplexe thema also steuersenkung für
unternehmen per gießkannenprinzip wird
uns nicht weiterbringen ich glaube das
ist der erste punkt unternehmen brauchen
bessere rahmenbedingen man kann sich
steuerlich fördern was
digitale transformation betrifft um mehr
zu investieren also gezielte förderung
bei innovationen gerade kleine mittlere
unternehmen brauchen diese unterstützung
ja aber keine flächendeckung das wird
nicht zu mehr investitionen für das
zweite und das ist genauso wichtig wir
haben in deutschland eine riesige
demografischen wandel vor uns wir haben
eine alterung die jetzt schon
eingetreten ist die beschäftigtenzahlen
werden irgendwann sinken wenn wir nicht
massive zuwanderung haben heißt die
sozialausgaben in der gesetzlichen
rentenversicherung im gesundheitsbereich
und an bereichen werden ansteigen also
zu sagen wir haben jetzt diese schönen
überschüsse lass uns doch mal die
steuern senken halte ich auch für für
nicht ehrlich weil man in drei vier
jahren realisiert diese einnahmen gehen
ja runter weil immer mehr menschen in
rente gehen immer weniger
arbeitnehmerinnen arbeitnehmer trifft
also wir brauchen auch da wieder diese
langfristige perspektive zu realisieren
die haben eine riesige herausforderung
der demokratischen wende mit unseren
sozialsystemen die finanziert werden
müssen
also dort will ist ein großes defizit
und schulden machen auch um künftige
sozialausgaben abfedern zu können
na das ist ja so ein bisschen
widerspruch sie werden ja jetzt nicht
schulden machen können um zusätzliche
sozialausgaben stemmen zu können sondern
klug in die junge generation investieren
denn wer zahlt denn die gesetzliche
rente das sind ja die die arbeitnehmerin
arbeitnehmern und wie ist es
finanzierbar ist es ja nur dann
finanzierbar wenn eine hohe
beschäftigung da ist wenn die
produktivität und die löhne der
arbeitnehmerin arbeitnehmer steigen nur
so können die rente auch in der zukunft
sicher sein und auch weiter steigen also
das hängt ja zusammen also kluge
zukunftsinvestitionen in junge
generation generationengerechtigkeit ist
ja auch im letztlich im interesse der
älteren menschen die damit ihre rente
erhalten also trotzdem ist man auch im
sozialsystem ehrlich sein wir haben auch
einschnitte im sozialsystem machen
müssen
wir werden wahrscheinlich im
rentensystem die lebensarbeitszeit
verlängern ist also auch da sind
schwierige entscheidungen nur ich glaube
dass alleine kann es nicht sein und die
bestmögliche lösung für all diese
herausforderung auch für
die systeme ist klug in die zukunft zu
investieren deutschland als
wirtschaftsstandort attraktiv zu machen
gute jobs zu sichern die hohe einkommen
generieren unternehmen anreize setzen
weiter in deutschland zu investieren dem
über telekom gesprochen viele der
dax-30-unternehmen gm immer stärker ins
ausland weil dort die rahmenbedingung
für investitionen besser sind hilfe also
wir müssen die rahmenbedingungen
verbessern so dass sie hier bleiben also
da bin ich bei man kann sich jetzt über
die instrumente streiten also wie gesagt
steuersenkung für unternehmen glaube ich
ist das geringste der probleme wir
brauchen bessere rahmenbedingungen also
bessere verkehrsinfrastruktur mehr
fachkräfte besseres bildungssystem ein
einfacheres steuersystem das ist glaube
ich was notwendig ist aber bei nicht in
eine steuersenkung per gießkannenprinzip
okay wenn wir jetzt die diskussion so
ein bisschen betrachten und auch
innerhalb der neuen spd-spitze
dann geht es ja doch sehr stark in
richtung abfederung also soziale
abfederung des strukturwandels ist das
die richtige akzentuierung aus ihrer
sicht oder müsste noch mehr richtung der
blick auf forschung entwicklung
digitalisierung gesteckt naja was heißt
finanzielle abfederung des
strukturwandels wir haben einen
permanenten strukturwandel und der wird
sich eher noch beschleunigen in den
nächsten jahren die frage ist hier haben
wir die ausreichend qualifizierten
mitarbeiter in den unternehmen die das
stemmen haben wir die unternehmen die
diesen strukturwandel begleiten nehmen
sie mal nur die gesamte plattform
technologie da ist deutschland leider
auch ganz europa weit zurück wir haben
praktisch keine unternehmen jeder
mithalten können haben wir eine
europäische cloud das ist nicht nur
irgendwo da oben eine wolke und mit ein
bisschen speicherkapazität das ist eine
zukunftsinvestition auch für die gesamte
volkswirtschaft die wir dringend
brauchen
ich sage mal so ein beispiel nur vier
prozent der daten die wir in europa
haben die wir jeden tag nutzen auf
unseren handys auf unseren rechnern in
jedem unternehmen in jedem privaten
haushalt nur vier prozent dieser daten
liegen auf europäischen rechnern 96
prozent liegen auf amerikanischen und
chinesischen rechnern die abhängigkeit
die wir von diesen systemen haben ist
viel zu groß das heißt wir brauchen auch
rechtlich absolut wir brauchen auch die
unternehmen die das leisten können dafür
brauchen wir rahmenbedingungen vater
dazu gehören natürlich die steuern die
steuerbelastung ist ein faktor für die
deutschen unternehmen für die
mittelständischen unternehmen sowie so
war sie überwiegend nach
der einkommensteuer belastet werden für
die großen unternehmen auch weil sie im
internationalen wettbewerb in
deutschland ein hochsteuerland vorfinden
dass wir diese unternehmen nicht haben
hat auch nicht nur aber auch etwas mit
der steuerbelastung zu tun so wenn wir
das insgesamt betrachten dann haben wir
zum jetzigen zeitpunkt nur auf den
beziehe ich mich und deswegen bin ich so
überrascht das land diesen vorschlägen
mit den neuverschuldungen immer kommen
haben zum jetzigen zeitpunkt kein
geldproblem wir haben eher ein problem
der wirklich guten rahmenbedingungen der
prioritäten wir müssen auch wieder
prioritäten setzen also wenn der
finanzminister sagt vor jahr und tag so
geschehen wir können uns alles leisten
sagt unser finanzminister dieser
bundesregierung wörtliches zitat wir
können uns alles leisten
ich habe zweifel daran ob das stimmt
aber wenn er das sagt dann gibt es
keinen grund jetzt von diesen
finanzpolitischen grundentscheidungen
der jetzigen regierungskoalition an der
stelle abzuweichen ich sehe wirklich zum
jetzigen zeitpunkt keinen grund kann
zwei oder drei jahren ändern
diese handelskonflikte sind da aber bis
jetzt haben die wenig auswirkungen auf
unsere volkswirtschaftliche leistung
deutschland steht im jahreswechsel 219
220 gut da wir müssen jetzt nur dafür
sorgen dass die nächsten zehn jahre aus
so bleibt die handys kommt fällt ja
nicht vom himmel und wenn die
bundesregierung sagt sie kann es sich
leisten und so sieht es auch tun und
dafür brauchen eine langfristige
strategie das reicht nicht zu sagen ja
wir könnten wenn wir wollten sondern
dann erfordert es wirklich eine vision
wo wollen wir in 15 jahren sein was ist
richtig sie haben das thema digitale
transformation also die die die großen
plattform also die googles apples
facebooks der welt sitzen nicht in
europa dann in deutschland sondern
sitzen in asien usa in anderen regionen
steuersenkung werden das problem nicht
löse ich will noch auf eine andere
dimension kommen das ist für mich europa
wir müssen realisieren in deutschland
wir sind wir haben ein kleines land mit
einer kleinen volkswirtschaft wir können
im globalen wettbewerb im politischen
konflikt mit usa und china nicht
mithalten
wir werden unsere interessen sei es beim
datenschutz bei ethischen standards bei
verbraucherschutz nur dann wirklich
wahren können wenn wir eine stärkere
europäische integration haben mit einer
stimme in europa spreche
nur dann können sie den usa paroli
bieten nur dann können wir unsere
interessen ab gegenüber china waren
deshalb ist diese weitere dimension auch
wir dürfen nicht nur hier in seinen
engen deutschen grenzen denken sagen ja
die anderen europäer die sind nicht so
mit sowie die wie die man se nicht so
gut sondern wir müssen realisieren wir
werden unsere interessen woran können
wenn wir auch mehr in europa investieren
steuern würde ich trotzdem mal ganz
gerne hier bei uns bleiben weil das
scheint mir doch ziemlich viel
uneinigkeit zu herrschen das neue
führungsduo der spd setzt sich ja auch
für höhere steuern ein mit
vermögenssteuer erbschaftssteuerreform
anhebung des spitzensteuersatzes drehen
sie damit an der steuerschraube
wir brauchen eine grundlegende reform
des steuersystems in vielen vielen
dimensionen
herr merz hatten wir angesprochen hat
unternehmenssteuer angesprochen er hat
einkommensteuer und abgaben betroffen
was auch soweit dazu gehört ist nicht
nur das unternehmen relativ hohe steuern
zahlen müssen sondern dass es kein
anderes land in der welt gibt wo
arbeitnehmerinnen aber nie mehr steuern
zahlen müssen und wo vermögen und
einkommen aus vermögen geringer
besteuert wird als in deutschland das
wir haben eine große unwucht und ein
problem auch für die unternehmen dass
dazu gehört dass wir noch nicht
besprochen haben ist fachkräftemangel
wir haben zunehmend zu wenig leute die
da sind die wichtige arbeit machen
können zum teil auch weil viele leute in
teilzeit arbeiten weil es sich nicht
lohnt mehr zu arbeiten weil einfach die
steuerliche belastung sehr hoch ist
gerade frauen hervorragend qualifiziert
ist das größte ungehobene
wirtschaftliche potenzial was wir in
deutschland haben werden häufig durch
ehegattensplitting durch fehlende kitas
durch fehlende ganztagsschulen stark
belastet und viele davon arbeiten in
teilzeit könnten mehr arbeiten also wenn
man über eine steuerliche reform
nachdenkt dann muss man auch darüber
nachdenken wie man arbeit entlastet dass
sich arbeit wieder lohnt und das
betrifft nicht die leute die den soli
zahlen am oberen ende sondern es
betrifft die wirklich die menschen der
mittelschicht in welchem bereich wären
sie denn für höhere steuern
ich denke für
ich wäre für eine stärkere belastung von
passiven vermögen nehmen sie das thema
erbschaftssteuern wir haben menschen die
weniger als erstes machen wir weniger
als die hälfte der deutschen überhaupt
was erben die menschen die zwischen 250
1500 euro erben zahlen im durchschnitt
zwölf prozent erbschaftssteuer die die
mehr als 20 millionen euro erben zahlen
im durchschnitt weniger als zwei prozent
erbschaftsteuer also da geht es
eigentlich um steuergerechtigkeit und
gleich bei aber freut sich wissen warum
und des unternehmens vererbungen die
aber genauso besteuert werden könnten
wie alle anderen auch und auch das
gehört dazu dass man ein faires
steuersystem hat wo alle gleich belastet
wenn also es war ein beispiel wo der
staat sicherlich über ein faires
steuersystem durchaus mehr
steuereinnahmen gewährleisten könnte
wären sie da dabei also ist nicht das
hielt so das sind so zahlen die hier so
in den innenraum geworfen werden und
deswegen habe ich dazwischen gerufen
das sind zum ganz grossen teil
unternehmen die das geld in den
unternehmen haben
die gehören dann der nächsten generation
wenn sie die mit 25 prozent abschlag
steuerbelastung machen die unternehmen
zu wenn sie mit fünf oder zehn prozent
belasten könnte und es nicht also mit
irgendwo der zehn prozent werden sie
belastet und die versöhnungs regel gilt
nur also ich bin nun in drei
erbschaftsteuerreform dabei gewesen ich
habe das ist eine endlose geschichte in
deutschland ja die letzte abschafft
steuerreform ist so gemacht worden dass
insbesondere die mittelständischen
eigentümergeführten unternehmen
verschont werden wenn sie die
arbeitsplätze erhalten und nur dann wenn
sie die arbeitsplätze erhalten haben sie
diese verschuldungsregeln das ist also
wirklich das ist jetzt im griff in die
mottenkiste mit den 100.000 und den 20
millionen das ist kein barvermögen was
die leute cash ausgezahlt bekommt
sondern es liegt in den betrieben und
wenn sie diese betriebs ganze machen
aber dann haben sie einen druck in die
kapitalgesellschaften dann sieht die
unternehmenslandschaft in deutschland in
zukunft genauso aus wie in amerika dann
haben wir keine privaten unternehmer
mehr sondern haben wir
kapitalgesellschaften die dann an den
aktienmärkten notiert sind und die
zahlen keine aircraft als die eigentümer
nämlich die aktionäre bezahlen müssen
noch nicht die unternehmen also wenn sie
diese unternehmenslandschaft in
deutschland beschädigen wollen oder
wirklich dann nachhaltig zerschlagen
wollen dann müssen sie mit der
erbschaftsteuer den weg geben den sieg
gegen den sie hier gerade vorschlagen
dann haben wir den mittelstand in
deutschland nicht
nein das ist ein drohszenario wir genau
wissen dass das nicht passieren wird
sie hatten doch alle gehabt genau man
kann eine erbschaftssteuer genau so
gestalten dass sie fair ist dass alle
gleich belastet werden dass man eine
substanzbesteuerung also das was sie
davor warnen das unternehmen probleme
kommen vermeiden kann
aber das gehört zu einer
erbschaftssteuer zu einer klugen
steuerreform dazu genauso wie reform von
grund und boden also gerade grundsteuer
wo es jetzt einen meiner ansicht nach
fauler kompromiss war der hier gefunden
wurde wog und boden relativ schwach
besteuert werden also hier geht es darum
die frage wie kann der staat die
aufgaben die er hat finanzieren und zur
wahrheit gehört dazu dass menschen
gerade mit mittleren und geringen
einkommen ungewöhnlich stark besteuert
werden und dazu gehört ist aus einer
ökonomischen sicht man kann über
gerechtigkeit streiten aber aus einer
ergonomischen sicht macht es viel sinn
menschen mit mittleren geringen
einkommen zu entlasten damit sich arbeit
mehr lohnt dass menschen auch wieder
mehr arbeiten können und das wäre eine
wirtschaftlich sinnvolle also diese
menschen mit niedrigen und mittleren
einkommen nun nur damit er einfach nur
mal wissen wo wir ja gerade sprechen 30
prozent der unteren einkommen in
deutschland hat überhaupt keine
einkommensteuer
ich finde wir der freibeträge völlig
draußen aber die zahlen mehrwertsteuer
damals sehr die inhaltlichen abkommen
das sind 40 prozent aller steuern wir
leben jetzt gerade mal über die direkten
steuern ich gerade stehe ja gut alles
gut also die mehrwertsteuer wird von
jedem bezahlt und der der hoch
konsumiert bezahlt mir schon als
derjenige der niedrig konzentrischen mit
geringen einkommen die ja ihr gesamtes
einkommen monatlich für den konsum
ausgeben so aber da liegt natürlich
mehrwertsteuer teilweise nur sieben
prozent drauf und einkommenssteuer 0
wenn sie in diesem bereich argumentiert
wenn uns und wir haben die obersten fünf
in deutschland 52 prozent der einkommen
steigt weil sie können das noch weiter
steigern
nur das löst die probleme nicht über die
wir so oft daher ganz gut gerade erleben
sind so die unterschiedlichen pole
dienste in diesem blick auch in der
großen koalition gibt auch wenn hier
nicht die große koalition am tisch sitzt
wie lange kann das denn noch so gut
gehen weil doch die positionen noch sehr
unterschiedlich sind
was glauben sie wie
die beiden weil ich nicht ich bin jetzt
ich immer der große liebe schon relativ
schnell sogar einig sind aber nur in der
großen koalition wird ja genau die
fragen werden jetzt auftauchen weil wir
haben auf der einen seite den überschuss
und es gibt ja jetzt schon forderungen
eine komplette abschaffung des soli
senkung der körperschaftssteuer andere
forderungen des neuen spd führungsduos
was glauben sie wie geht es jetzt die
nächsten wochen weiter vielleicht mal
zuerst ich befürchte dass man sich auf
wird nichts mit einigen können dass wir
so ein bisschen in der schwebe bleiben
das anderthalb jahre zwei jahre bis zur
neuen wahlen nicht viel passieren wird
das wäre nicht gut für deutschland wir
haben über die herausforderung
gesprochen die eigentlich anstehen ich
glaube es steht eine klare entscheidung
an man muss privatisieren muss sagen ja
der staat steht hervorragend da was die
was sie gelder betrifft was er
eigentlich tun kann wofür er geld hat
muss jetzt entscheiden was wir da tun
steuern senken unternehmen
besserverdiener entlasten will er leicht
auch die privaten haushalte wenn sie
einfach nur der vollständigkeit halber
auch dazu nehmen die privaten haushalte
unternehmen wissen jeder ist ein
unterton immer drin bei ihm ich rede
über eine gesamte entlastung auch derer
die hier im raum sitzen auch die
zahllosen beiträge werden bei dem es so
wenn man den soli sprechen das sind dann
die oberen zehn prozent die den der
jetzt noch nicht abgeschafft wird da
werden ja weil der stadt marl den soli
erhoben hat um die finanzierungslasten
der deutschen einheit von allen bezahlen
zu lassen so wenn die
finanzierungslasten beendet sind dann
muss auch für alle beendet sein dass er
so leerung glauben sie dass comcast dann
hätte anschaffen er kommt und zwar ganz
einfach durch bundesverfassungsgericht
ja weil sowie die koalition das gemacht
hat
auf druck der spd eine zustimmung auch
von einigen
wirtschaftsforschungsinstituten das mit
unserer verfassung nicht übereinstimmt
nur ganz einfach wir haben der soli ist
gemacht worden zur refinanzierung der
deutschen einheit das kapitel ist am 31
12 2019 abgeschlossen so er wird jetzt
abgeschafft nicht für die oberen zehn
prozent nicht sondern für 50 prozent des
aufkommens wird abgeschafft und 50
prozent des aufkommens bleibt so das
geht nach karlsruhe
und dann lassen sich meine begründung
einfallen warum in karlsruhe das halten
soll was der gesetzgeber vorher 20 jahre
lang anders versprochen hat
das ist glaubwürdigkeit wie der
verfassungs- und wie der
steuergesetzgeber handelt ja so wenn er
sagen will ich will das geld haben dann
soll er den einkommensteuertarif ändern
ich habe übrigens selber den vorschlag
gemacht den spitzensteuersatz anzuheben
aber dann zwischendurch den
mittelstandsbauch da raus zu nehmen und
die facharbeiter die sie eben genannt
haben rauszunehmen aus der progression
ein facharbeiter der heute 100 euro mehr
verdient zahlt davon 40 euro steuern
weil er in den obersten provisions satz
ist das muss man ändern so aber nicht so
steuergesetzgebung machen dass das alles
hinterher nach karlsruhe geht und in
karlsruhe aufgehoben wird das sind sehr
blamiert sich die regierung und blamiert
sich das parlament und damit die
wissenschaftler dies befürwortet haben
naja erstmal märz zur wahrheit wird auch
dazu dass in den letzten 20 jahren die
30 prozent verbessert bei denen
deutschland steuerlich entlastet wurden
sie zahlen einen geringeren anteil ihres
einkommens monatlich an steuern die
unteren 70 prozent stärker belastet und
es geht auch so kommen die zahlen her
wird das inoffizielle zahlen wo kommen
die her die dann rechnen sie dann aber
alles zusammen sozusagen die
sozialversicherungsbeiträge setzen mehr
wäre dann also nicht steuern sondern
dann sagen sie abgaben steuerzahler soll
seine steuererklärung wird auch dazu
also mehrwertsteuer ist auch eine steuer
wir haben was geht was lunch mit
geringen einkommen zu einem tieferen
verhält zahlen als einkommen also sie
haben drei möglichkeiten mit den
überschüssen steuersenkungen
entlastungen von unternehmen und wir
haben das genannt privathaushalten
zweiter
sie machen zukunftsinvestitionen in die
zukunft also versuchen zu sagen so wir
geben das geld für bildung für
innovation für infrastruktur aus oder
das dritte ist sie versuchen die
schulden weiter zu reduzieren und für
mich ist klar man wird nicht alles drei
erreichen können man muss eine priorität
setzen und für mich ganz klar die
priorität bei den zukunftsinvestitionen
weil es letztlich auch wirtschaftlich
das solideste ist okay wir haben gemerkt
dass die finanzpolitik wohl das
entscheidende
streitthema für die kommenden wochen
sein wird wir haben mit personen
angefangen
letzte frage wie lange wird olaf scholz
noch finanzminister sein was glauben sie
also man kann es für diese koalition
eigentlich nur hoffen aber die
sozialdemokraten müssen ist am ende des
tages entscheiden ich glaube er ist ein
stabilitätsfaktor für diese koalition
aber diese koalition hat mittlerweile
andere kraftzentren andere macht sind
drin und das wird eine spannende frage
der nächsten wochen und monate sein
das haben sie ich denke bis zur nächsten
bundestagswahl also ich denke die
koalition wird durchhalten und man ist
gut findet oder nicht auseinander
mit einem minister es gibt ja durchaus
vorschläge für kabinetts wechsel aber
ich denke es wird keine großen änderung
geben ja ok wunderbar vielen dank in
beiden für die diskussion
vielen dank ihnen fürs zuschauen es aus
berlin
[Applaus]
[Musik]